[Music]
verne troyer has died he was 49 the
actors team took to Instagram to share
the sad news with fans writing in part
it is with great sadness and incredibly
heavy hearts to write that Vern passed
away depression and suicide are very
serious issues you never know what kind
of battles someone is going through
inside earlier this month
multiple outlets reported Vern was
placed on a 5150 hold following police
being called out to his home after
allegedly being told he was suicidal
Vern was best known for his role as
mini-me in the Austin Powers franchise I
shall call him mini-me and in a
statement to ET mike myers who starred
alongside Vern
paid tribute to his former co-star Vern
was the consummate professional and a
beacon of positivity for those of us who
had the honor of working with him it is
a sad day but I hope he is in a better
place he will be greatly missed other
stars took to social media to share
their condolences and fond memories of
the actor rapper Ludacris shared this
throwback from his 2005 Austin Powers
themed music video for number one spot
which Byrne starred in while Shannon
Elizabeth posted a sweet photo with
Troyer
tweeting rest in peace and fly with the
Angels Vern
[Music]